faut leur redonner espoir chaque
décision doit prise doit être repensée
pour résoudre l'urgence et en même temps
réparer le présent et préparer l'avenir
c'est essentiel si nous voulons recréer
la confiance perdue prendre des mesures
efficaces et en tirer les enseignements
la crise est toujours une grande menace
qui frappe mais c'est aussi toujours une
opportunité à saisir
les français ne vous suivent plus
monsieur le premier ministre
ils ne sont pas dupes ils ont adopté
dans leur immense majorité un
comportement exemplaire ils ont bien vu
ce qui marche et ce qui ne marchait pas
ce manque de transparence des coupes et
des modes de décisions parfois
consternante leurs réactions sont
sévères ils ont salué le dévouement de
certains d'entre eux que l'on n'oubliera
jamais tant de personnes mobilisées
arras et qui au péril de leur vie ont
sauver celle des autres
quel magnifique sens donner à nos
existences ces personnes cependant outre
notre gratitude attendent désormais des
actes
il est temps d'annoncer de véritables
augmentations salariales pour ce
personnel
cette catastrophe doit nous amener à
redonner des couleurs à notre devise
républicaine la liberté le respect des
libertés publiques et individuelles est
fondamentale
l'égalité tous égaux en dignité la
fraternité frères et soeurs de notre si
beau et si magnifique pays la france 300
mille parmi nous vivent sans papiers
comment pouvez vous les laisser dans les
situations sanitaires et sociales si
inhumaine
mais au delà des millions souffrent il
est temps d'agir et de leur donner un
toit pour tous et un revenu décent pour
celles et ceux qui n'en n'ont pas notre
devoir est de n'oublier personne et de
prendre en compte les situations de tous
à commencer par les plus fragiles pour
lesquels la crise sanitaire social et
économique a des effets dramatiques
les français sont déboussolés monsieur
le premier ministre et la cacophonie au
plus haut niveau de l'état n'a fait que
de renforcer l' angoisse et l'anxiété
trop de brouillon leur ont été présentés
la pénurie de masques de respirateurs de
test les annonces contradictoires ont
démontré l'absence totale dont il
si passion de l'état qui réagit toujours
avec un train de retard en termes de
stratégie ou de logistique sur laquelle
notre groupe
par la voix de françois michel lambert
vous a souvent alerté
nombreux sont ceux qui font référence au
livre de marc bloch l'étrange défaite et
plus personne n'ignore les
dysfonctionnements désastreux de l'état
central cette bureaucratisation extrême
qui gangrène notre pays n'est pas
nouvelle
il est temps d'y remédier il faut
engager un nouvel acte de
décentralisation et libérer les
territoires
comment voulez vous que tout fonctionne
bien quand c'est le même qui décide de
tout les annonces du président de la
république concernant la date du
déconfinement où on en était
l'illustration la plus cinglante un
président seul qui décide seul de la
date du 11 mai et des ministres au
garde-à-vous qui exécutent puis tiennent
des propos embarrassait pour revenir en
arrière avant d'être démentie par le
chef sans parler du conseil scientifique
comment voulez vous entraîner l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens avec une telle
pagaille
pourquoi ne pas avoir voulu partager les
décisions quand elles sont difficiles à
prendre
et pourquoi se dessaisir des
contre-pouvoirs le législatif des
saisies par ordonnance non juridique des
portées par le biais du conseil
constitutionnel le médiatique éloigné de
toute question lors des déclarations du
président de la république les
collectivités territoriales se
débrouillent seuls pire elles sont
parfois entravés par l'état les
organisations professionnelles et la
société civile quant à elle gronde
la décision de fermer puis d'ouvrir les
écoles auraient pu être prise en lien
étroit avec les parents d'élèves les
collectivités locales les enseignants
vous ne l'avez pas fait et aujourd'hui
ce serait plus rationnel de ne tout
rouvrir qu'en septembre
il aurait été si simple parfois pour
l'exécutif ne peut construire est de
fédérer les synergies plutôt que de
faire appliquer ce qui avait été décidé
dans les ministères
8 vous avez réuni non vous n'avez pas
écouté
si tu veux construire un bateau ne
rassemble pas des hommes et des femmes
pour leur donner des ordres pour
expliquer chaque détail pour leur dire
où
je trouve chaque chose si tu veux
construire un bateau fait naître dans le
coeur de tes hommes et de ces femmes le
désir de la maire écrit saint-exupéry
cette maxime qu'il faut désormais mettre
en oeuvre avant que notre bateau commun
ne se transforme en radeau de la méduse
et bien cette maxime mettons la en
oeuvre maintenant les français attendent
en femme sur le premier ministre que
vous décidiez après avoir associé et non
pas devoir vous écoutez après que vous
ayez décidé
il faut que l'on se mette une bonne fois
pour toutes en tête de travailler
collectivement plus les sujets sont
complexes plus les décisions doivent
être prises de façon collective
comment penser disposer des conditions
d'une sortie de crise quand les masques
ne sont pas en nombre suffisant
ce en accord avec les collectivités et
les entreprises sur qui fait quoi
les achats les volumes les calendriers
alors que l'on a assisté ces dernières
semaines à temps de cacophonie quand
c'est le conseil régional du grand test
qui achètent des masques pour protéger
des personnes travaillant dans ces pour
ses compétences c'est-à-dire économiques
scolaires et transport et qui tout en re
cédait 2 millions aux services de santé
régionaux qui dépendent de l'état
cherchez l'erreur quand les communes ne
savent pas quel type et nombre
d'équipements elles doivent se procurer
parce qu'elle ignore comment les
services publics vont réouvrir chercher
encore erreur les collectivités locales
n'ont heureusement n'ont pas attendu
pour pallier les déficiences de l'état
dans la fourniture des équipements
mettre en place les fonds
d'accompagnement économique partout en
france
elles ont été très réactives agile et
ont su se fédérer
mais les françaises et les français ont
regardé tout cela les yeux médusés
les français attendent monsieur le
premier ministre
enfin que vous les informiez maintenant
en toute transparence afin de ne pas
rajouter de la confusion à la confusion
des peurs hopper nous avons besoin d'une
mobilisation collective pour gérer la
crise la poursuite du confinement et sa
levée collective et la reprise
indispensable de l'activité nous
attendons toujours les bons de commande
des masques que je vous ai demandé ainsi
que la traçabilité
tu es de leur livraison nous attendons
toujours l'estimation du nombre de
contaminés par des contacts dans les
maisons médicales ou celui du nombre de
décès réel du coc vide c'est-à-dire en
incluant celui des décès à domicile
après avoir trop longtemps tardé sur
celui des ehpad informer en toute
transparence
savoir écouter décider collectivement ce
devrait être la règle de base de toute
politique publique être transparent
écoutez décider collectivement c'est la
règle de la réussite et la clé d'entrée
dans le nouveau monde dont vous n'avez à
vrai dire pas encore trouvé la porte
ces principes n'ont pas marqué votre
politique depuis votre arrivée au
pouvoir monsieur le premier ministre il
y avait pourtant tant d' alerte vous
invitant à le faire c'était clairement
l'enseignement de la crise des gilets
jaunes
c'était très clairement l'enseignement
de la contestation des retraites être
transparent dans les décisions
les décentraliser les partager et donner
du sens à nos politiques publiques
il est vraiment dommage que cette crise
majeure ne vous ai pas donné l'occasion
de changer
vous avez perdu monsieur le premier
ministre la bataille de l'opinion
publique mais il n'est encore jamais
trop tard pour bien faire
afin de ne pas faire s'aggraver les
autres gigantesque crise sanitaire
sociale économique et écologique qui
sont annoncés car il convient désormais
d'anticiper les projets les prochaines
crises encore plus dévastatrice qui sont
devant nous nos enfants nous regardent
ils nous regardent ils nous regardent
avec leurs grands yeux pleins d'espoir
et plein de rêves nos aînés connaissent
vraiment ce que le mot guerre veut dire
ce que l'on a réussi et ce qu'on a raté
nos concitoyens savent ce que nous
devons à notre histoire à nos combats
pour la liberté à notre culture des
générations entières ont enrichi notre
pays
ils ont travaillé dur en croyant que
nous étions l'un des berceaux de la cie
des civilisations tous savent que c'est
le moment de rompre avec nos mauvaises
habitudes et tous nos conforts et c'est
vraiment pour eux que nous nous battons
pour qu'il soit enfin heureux et fiers
d'habiter dans notre beau pays à france
vous nous demandez de vous donner un
quitus nous vous demandons de préserver
l'espérance la confiance est l'une des
conditions majeures pour sortir la
réussie pour réussir la sortie de la
crise
or les conditions de préparation du plan
de déconfinement et ce vote organisé à
l'assemblée dans les conditions de
précipitation a exacerbé la défiance
vous comprendrez que nous ne pouvons
malheureusement pas vous accorder notre
confiance beaucoup d'hirondelles
monsieur le premier ministre annonce le
printemps
ne cherchez pas en permanence à les
mettre en cage merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur le président
jean luc mélenchon pour le groupe la
france
insoumise
[Applaudissements]
présidents ministres collègues nous
n'allons pas voter ce qui nous est
proposé
non en raison de votre personne sur le
premier ministre ni même de l'idée que
nous nous faisons de votre action nous
sommes certains que vous faites pour le
mieux mais nous ne partageons niveau
diagnostic ni le système d'action que
vous avez choisi au demeurant on voit
bien que vous êtes aujourd'hui le bouc
émissaire de confort de toutes sortes de
gens a commencé dans votre propre
majorité
ce n'est pas notre état d'esprit notre
état d'esprit c'est de discuter les
contenus les faits d'une manière
rationnelle
car nous croyons que c'est la raison qui
peut nous tirer des difficultés dans
lesquelles la patrie se trouve au
demeurant vous n'êtes pas le responsable
des diagnostics erronés en première
ligne en première ligne comment oublier
à propos de l'épidémie le 24 janvier
ces déclarations de madame agnès buzyn
de triste mémoire dans l'hôpital public
le risque d'importation de cas depuis
lujan et modérée il est maintenant
pratiquement nul
parce que la ville est isolée les
risques de cas secondaires autour d'un
cas importé sont très faibles et les
risques de propagation du corps en habit
russes sont très faibles
on pourrait lui faire porter la
responsabilité de cette déclaration et
de celle qu'elle a fait ensuite en
prétendant vous avoir informée du danger
ce qui ne se voit pas à cette
déclaration
mais comment alors comprendre le
président de la république le 3 mars le
3 mars déclarant il est encore trop tôt
pour dire si la france passera au stade
de l'épidémie
les masques dont tout le monde convient
à présent qu'ils sont indispensables et
font partie en quelque sorte des
instruments barrière élémentaires dont
vous dites vous même monsieur le premier
ministre qu'il faudra en faire porter
dans les transports et vous avez raison
de dire qu'il le faudra notamment quand
vous verrez qu'il ne sert à rien de dire
aux gens de ne pas prendre le métro pour
leur plaisir car ils sont fort rares
ceux qui sont dans cette situation
je vous invite à aller voir comment ça
se passe sur la ligne 13
les gens font ce qu'ils font parce
qu'ils y sont obligés non parce qu'ils
sont déraisonnables
en attendant sur ce masque le 13 avril
monsieur macron déclarait je refuse
aujourd'hui de recommander le port du
masque le 13 avril pour tous et jamais
le gouvernement ne l'a fait si nous le
recommandons ce serait incompréhensible
le 13 les tests dont l' oms a dit dès le
15 mars qu'il fallait tester tester
tester encore formule qui a été reprise
entre temps par d'autres après qu'on
nous est dit dans cet hémicycle que cela
ne servait à rien
le président macron le 23 avril d'éclat
le 15 mars le msg qu'il faut que tout le
monde le fath le 23 avril le président
macron d'éclat nous n'allons pas testé
toutes les françaises et tous les
français
ça n'aurait pas de sens et enfin le
confinement acquis de haute lutte après
combien d'efforts de conviction fait est
bien le président lui encore le 6 mars
sortait du théâtre est déclarée la vie
continue il n'y a aucune raison
mise à part pour les populations
fragilisées de modifier nos habitudes de
sortie voilà dans quel état d'esprit
cette terrible crise a été abordé par
ceux qui commandaient ordres et
contre-ordres se sont succédé tant et si
bien que s'est brisé et c'est pour cela
que je mentionne toutes ces citations
tant et si bien que c'est briser le
ressort fondamental de la lutte la
confiance car en démocratie il n'y a pas
de consentement à l'autorité sans
conscience dans la légitimité des
consignes qui sont données et cette
confiance est morte
je ne suis pas sûr monsieur le premier
ministre qu'il faille vous en rendre
vous responsable mais celui qui a pris
toutes ces décisions est tenu ces propos
alors qu'il occupe la plus éminente
place dans la république lui doit en
être tenu pour responsable et je me
risque à cette critique en prenant la
mesure des menaces qu'il a proférées
contre ce qui comptait le critiquer le
président maquereau en effet le 31 mars
a dit quand cette crise sera passée on
aura tous à rendre des comptes
tous sans exception
la majorité bien évidemment je crois que
ça va être pour vous monsieur le premier
ministre
et c'est normal vous savez avec quels
mots vous êtes prêté dans un quotidien
de droite qui dans le passé vous a été
favorable mais aussi dit le président
macron tous ceux qui ont joué à certains
moments un jeu dangereux pour
déstabiliser le pays dans une période où
l'unité prévalait nous n'avons jamais
pour notre part joué aucun jeu dangereux
ni personne sur ses bancs nous avons
juge jouer le jeu de la démocratie qui
consiste à dire avec sens des
responsabilités et plus de mesures que
vous ne le croyez
ce qu'il était nécessaire de dire pour
mettre en garde et si vous n'y croyez
pas alors vous ne pouvez pas croire un
seul jour à la démocratie parce que
l'essence de la démocratie c'est
justement d'entendre des gens qui disent
des choses désagréables parce qu'ils
sont pas de votre avis à présent nous
voici rendus après une gestion
calamiteuse à une sortie hasardeuse
nous avons alerté le 30 mars par une
tribune collective de tous les
parlementaires d'insoumis vous disant il
est temps de parler de déconfinement
certains commentateurs considérant le
peuple français comme une assemblée
bruyante deux jeunes gens instable
disait qu'il ne fallait pas prononcer le
mot de peur que les gens ne viennent à
en conclure qu'il pouvait tout sortir de
chez eux et partir aller faire la fête
comme si ce peuple n'avait pas fait la
démonstration au milieu de tous ces
ordres et contre ordres au contraire
d'une magnifique et terrible discipline
dont il faut lui rendre tout l'hommage
et toute la grâce quand bien même temps
deux fois il aura été montré du doigt
par ces mêmes commentateurs sortie
hasardeuse il faut planifier planifier
et non pas 3 que le libre marché
la libre comment dire motivation des
individus va suffire à remplir les
conditions qu'il faut remplir pour que
ce 11 mai puisse être autre chose qu'une
aventure d'ailleurs les observateurs
attentifs auront remarqué que cette
décision a été prise par le président de
la république et lui seul sans tenir
compte du gouvernement sans tenir compte
de l'assemblée nationale sans tenir
compte du comité scientifique qu'il a
pourtant lui-même nommé et nous avons
entendu avec la délicatesse qu'on
apporte à ce genre de moments
premier ministre nous dire que lui-même
n'est pas bien sûr que le 11 mai on
lèvera le confinement parce que si
certaines conditions que l'on
observerait venait à le pousser à
décider autrement on décidera autrement
heureusement que vous le dites monsieur
le premier ministre parce que sinon nous
aurions très peur le 11 mais hélas il
est possible que le déconfinement ne
puisse pas se produire car nous savons
depuis le début que le déconfinement est
indispensable mais encore kobe est
indispensable faut-il le préparer avec
tout le sérieux nécessaire
voici venu le moment d injonction
odieuse vous n'avez pas été précis sur
ce point monsieur le premier ministre
les enfants doivent-ils aller à l'école
obligatoire le 11 mai ou bien sur la
base du volontariat
comme l'a dit votre ministre de
l'éducation nationale parce que ça c'est
anxiogène des millions de familles se
sont dit qu'est ce que je dois faire
qu'est ce que je dois faire voilà ce que
les gens viennent de vivre comment
peut-on demander aux paras d'évaluer le
risque d'exploser leurs enfants aux
dangers
c'est odieux oui c'est odieux ne savent
que faire les braves gens et surtout
quand leur décision n'est pas libres
parce qu'on leur dit il faut maintenant
retourner au travail c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on commence par les plus
petits parce qu'ils ne sont pas capables
de se surveiller eux-mêmes alors que les
plus grands pourrait le faire et pour
les enseignants des spas au dieu de
mettre en balance leur conscience
professionnelle leur attachement aux
enfants qu'ils éduquent et leur propre
rist leur évaluation du risque pour eux
et pour leurs familles voilà ce que
j'appelle les injonctions odieuse et
pour les travailleurs qui vont aller sur
leur poste de travail sans qu'on leur
garantisse qu'ils aient un masque pour
se protéger et sans que vous ayez
ordonné comme c'est votre responsabilité
de le faire ordonner pas suggérer
ordonné que les travailleurs puissent
avoir des réunions de collectifs de
sûreté sanitaire sur les lieux de
travail pour décider de contrôle et d'un
point de vue sanitaire
la production et les conditions de la
production voilà maintenant ce qu'il
faut dire monsieur le premier ministre
et qui fait que je m'étonne qu'autant de
gens dans votre propre camp vie votre
place c'est que la deuxième vague de
l'épidémie est inéluctable
le deuxième pic est inéluctable et sera
d'autant plus violent
que les conditions n'auront pas été
réunies pour réussir la sortie du 11 mai
il n'y aura ni la quantité de masques
suffisantes c'est-à-dire celle qui
permet à cette personne de disposer d'un
masque efficace sans qu'il lui en coûte
1 euro
parce qu'il s'agit de sa propre survie
et que si on trouve trois milliards pour
air france on peut en trouver autant
pour tous les français et que leurs
masques leur soit donné gratuitement
comme on dit parce qu'il n'y aura pas la
quantité de tests parce qu'il n'y aura
pas la capacité d'hébergement
quarantaine qui nécessiterait des
réquisitions dans le système hospital
dans le système hôteliers des
réquisitions de la totalité de
l'industrie textile pour qu'ils
produisent les masques dont nous avons
besoin
à l'image du maroc que nous devrions
imité dans ce domaine parce qu'il
parvient à cette performance
oui bah le maroc c'est très bien c'est
mon pays natal et je pense qu'ils
méritent votre admiration le plan déjà
soumis nous l'avions préparer monsieur
le premier ministre pour vous le
soumettre et en parler avec vous ils
étaient près d'une discussion le 5 mai
au bien sûr nous n'avons pas les moyens
dont vous disposez c'est normal qu'ils
sont ceux de l'état finalement il aura
fallu le publier alors même que cette
rencontre n'est plus possible
alors vous en connaissez les principes
je les ai rappelés mais mes derniers
mots seront pour vous dire que si la
planification doit être celle des
besoins des moyens matériels ce doit
être aussi celle de certains moyens vous
avez évoqué surtout les cons tous les
tons la grande guerre mais pendant la
grande guerre ils ont décidé qu'il y
aurait un moratoire des loyers fait le
pendant la grande guerre
ils ont décidé qu'il y aura un impôt sur
les profiteurs de guerre
7le et monsieur le premier ministre élu
de milieux populaires comme d'autres ici
je veux à tout prix que vous entendiez
cette parole là sa menace dans certains
quartiers en france et c'est
l'organisation admirable spontanée des
habitants qui fait que celle ça ne fait
pas davantage de dégâts parmi nous mais
quand même elle travaille les masses
j'achève nous vivons un événement global
monsieur le premier ministre
au départ un événement écologique qu'il
est devenu un événement biologie
il devient un événement économique il
sera un événement social
maintenant avec des millions de chômeurs
et pour finir ce sera un événement
politique
nous n'échapperons pas à cet
enchaînement puisse la patrie qui vient
de rehausser la valeur et où j'achève
souveraineté indépendance colocalisés
nous nous a changés habile public voilà
en crise sanitaire monsieur le premier
ministre
j'espérais recueillir au moins sérieux
de la tension entre et sanitaires c'est
la mobilisation populaire qui est la clé
comme toujours le peuple n'est pas le
problème mais la solution il faut qu'ils
aient confiance
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur stéphane peu pour le
groupe de la gauche démocrate et
républicaine pour dix minutes
vous avez la parole chocolat
[Musique]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues
après nous avoir convié à débattre cet
après midi d'une application qui
n'existe pas voilà que vous nous
convoquer à un débat bâclé sur un plan
de déconfinement que les parlementaires
n'ont pas eu le loisir de découvrir ou
d'amendés en réalité ce que vous voulez
n'est pas même un avis mais simplement
la confiance or cette confiance vous est
moins que jamais acquise car si
l'ampleur comme la soudaineté de cette
crise sanitaire nous a longtemps conduit
à réfréner nos critiques cela ne suffit
pas à expliquer la préparation total de
votre gouvernement et ses hésitations
impréparation car le risque d'une
pandémie hautement pathogène et à forte
létalité étaient connus depuis longtemps
faute d'avoir écouté les alertes
multiples comme celle de l'om est sous
de la banque mondiale qui en septembre
dernier exhorté les nations à je cite
mettre en place les systèmes et la
collaboration nécessaire pour détecter
et combattre les flambées épidémiques
potentiel le rapport concluait les
responsables de tous niveaux où les
cartes en main que faisiez-vous au temps
où ces recommandations étaient publiés
que faisiez-vous lorsque les personnels
de santé les urgences et les chefs de
service hospitaliers du pays vous
implorer depuis des mois de débloquer
les moyens qui faisait défaut
rien car vous étiez trop occupé à
moderniser notre système de santé ce qui
dans votre langue est synonyme de
dégrader car ce que nous avons sous les
yeux n'est pas le seul fruit d'une à
préparation mais aussi celui d'un froid
projet que d'autres ont certes engagés
avant vous mais que vous avez
opiniâtrement poursuivi 4,2 milliards
d'euros de moins pour la santé dans le
budget 2020 dont 1 milliard au détriment
de l'hôpital public
en vingt ans cent mille lits ont été
supprimés dont dix sept mille cinq cent
depuis six ans
au nom du dogme de la libre entreprise
et de l'idée d'une france sans usines
vous avez accepté le déménagement de
notre industrie aux quatre coins du
monde et poursuivi consciencieusement
l'affaiblissement de notre capacité à
produire à portée de malades est à
portée de soignants
ce qui est indispensable aux soins les
antidouleurs les antibiotiques les
matériel de réanimation ou encore les
protections et après avoir dégradé
maintenant vous pataugez oui vous
cafouillé en multipliant les
déclarations et décisions
contradictoires asséné avec assurance et
immédiatement démenti par les faits ou
par l'un des vôtres
pas de risque de propagation depuis yann
expliqué fin janvier la ministre de la
santé tout en alertant paraît-il le
premier ministre de la gravité de la
pandémie
pas besoin de dépister systématiquement
une doctrine défendu contre l'avis de
l'om s et les résultats obtenus dans
d'autres pays
et au moment même où vous invitiez les
français à rester chez eux
votre ministre du travail exhorté à la
rouvrir à rouvrir les chantiers dans le
bâtiment cafouillage aussi sur les
masques en déployant une irresponsable
argumentation sur leur inutilité pour
cacher la pénurie votre doctrine est
simple ce qui fait défaut n'est pas
indispensable en est la semaine dernière
nous avons appris médusés que ce soit
des 10000 respirateur commandes et 8500
ne sont pas adaptés aux malades du colis
de 19
comment voulez vous que les français
aient confiance
l'édifice de vos méthodes managériale
bâti sur le sable de votre imaginaire
libéral tout s'est effondré
et pourtant nous sommes convaincus que
l'ensemble des français que toutes les
forces vives du pays notamment ses
forces sociales et politiques dont la
nôtre sont prêtes à se retrousser les
manches et à se mettre autour de la
table
j'en ai la démonstration tous les jours
dans mon département de seine saint
denis où la méthode qui prévaut et celle
des efforts conjoints et de la recherche
du consensus
mais au lieu de faire ce choix de
l'unité vous restée crispée sur votre
dogme libéral qui vous pousse vers des
méthodes autoritaires
résultat vous nous invitez à débattre
sur un coin de table d'un plan de
déconfinement et d'une application qui
semble promise
au même destin puisque sur ce sujet
aussi nous continuons de parler dans le
vague
monsieur le premier ministre lorsqu'un
immeuble est en flammes et qu'on ne
dispose ni de lances à incendie ni
d'échelle ni même de soldats du feu en
nombre suffisant on ne se demande pas
s'il faut lancer une application mobile
pour prévenir les pompiers
d'autant qu'un tel dispositif
technologique de traçage percute
dangereusement nos valeurs républicaines
les menaces incontestablement nos
libertés sinon notre sinon notre
souveraineté
en outre ce dispositif n'a aucun sens
s'il ne vient pas complété une réponse
globale solide celle que nous aurions
aimé contribuer à élaborer à partir des
nombreuses propositions que nous avons
construites ces dernières semaines avec
nos collègues avec mes collègues
communistes en lien avec notre réseau
d'élus locaux avec les associations ou
les organisations syndicales
mes chers collègues il est temps de
sortir du flou des discours du président
de la république en lâchant au juge et
un déconfinement pour le 11 mai sans qu
à l'évidence on ne se soient préoccupés
en amont de savoir si c'était possible
et surtout à quelle condition
le président n'est pas le dernier malgré
des paroles paroles parfois martial
tantôt martiales tantôt mielleuse à
avoir contribué à semer le trouble
trouble car pour nombre de familles qui
aspire à la reprise de l'école pour
leurs enfants
le choix de cette date du 11 mai apparu
comme répondant à un objectif
essentiellement de remise au travail des
salariés et non comme la date à laquelle
toute précaution est en prise il est
possible de reprendre l'école dans des
conditions sanitaires adaptés un trouble
qui s'est renforcée lorsque le ministre
de l'éducation nationale a indiqué que
cette reprise était laissée au libre
choix des parents
alors que depuis jules ferry dans notre
pays l'école est obligatoire
beaucoup de salariés n'auront pas ce
choix ce qui peut conduire à renforcer
l'idée d'un deux poids deux mesures à
culpabiliser les parents et à creuser un
peu plus les inégalités sociales et
scolaires que cette crise a aiguisé
malgré toute la bonne volonté et
l'investissement des enseignants cette
reprise du 1 au 11 mai ne sera pas une
rentrée il faudra dès septembre engagé
un plan de rattrapage massif
et notamment en intégrant dans les
futurs programmes ce qui aurait pu être
appris pendant cette période afin de ne
pas entériner les inégalités scolaires
il faut aussi sortir du flou sur les
points les plus essentiels d'un plan de
déconfinement affirmer le droit aux
masques gratuits pour toute la
population est garantie par l'état est
la condition pour le rendre obligatoire
par exemple dans les transports en
commun et j'ai une pensée pour les
usagers de ma circonscription de la
ligne 13 qu'ils ont rebaptisé la ligne
de l'enfer mettre également massivement
et régulièrement des tests à disposition
de la population et ainsi mettre
permettre le suivi des périodes des
personnes testées positives au coville
19 ou encore soumettre toute reprise
d'activité d'une entreprise à
l'expertisé la proposition et
l'approbation du comité économique et
social de ladite entreprise alors
seulement nous serions disponible pour
écouter les variations du président de
la république autour de la france
d'après déclarations qui ont été
immédiatement contredites par vos
premières décisions
ainsi le pays applaudi chaque soir ces
soignants ces ambulanciers ces pompiers
mais qu'on soit à la france d'après
c'eût été octroyée enfin et durablement
dès votre projet de loi de finances
rectificative les moyens dans l'hôpital
public a tant besoin pour que son bon
fonctionnement
ne repose plus sur le sol dévouement
exceptionnel de ses personnels au moment
où certains découvrent soudain la france
des invisibles ces salariés qui en nous
ravitaillent en nous transportant en
collectant nos déchets font tenir le
pays debout conçoit la france d'après
serait déjà de contraindre les
entreprises qui chipotent et rechigne à
verser la prime promise aux salariés de
la seconde ligne et ce serait surtout en
augmentant le smic et en convoquant une
conférence sur l'augmentation des
salaires reconnaître enfin la
contribution économique et sociale
réelle de ces salariés de lyon de
l'ombre reconnaissance que le marché du
travail se trouve incapable de traduire
par une juste rémunération
quand en même temps le montant des
dividendes bat des records année après
année le président se dit prêt à
remettre en cause ses propres certitudes
mais rien ne témoigne de cette prise de
conscience dans ces actes construisent
construire la france d'après ce n'est
pas délivrée à nouveau
des chèques aux grandes entreprises sans
contrepartie comme vous venez de le
faire pour air france ce serait bien au
contraire de conditionner les aides à
une réorientation de l'économie évalué
sur sa performance sociale et sa
performance environnementale et ne pas
écarter le principe des nationalisations
permettant le retour d'une maîtrise
publique au service de la transition
écologique construire la france d'après
ce n'est pas octroyé toujours plus de
pouvoir discrétionnaire au patronat pour
déroger à la durée du temps de travail
ou au repos dominical ce serait au
contraire redonner du pouvoir aux
salariés par exemple celui que vous leur
avez ôté de peser sur les conditions
sanitaires de travail en supprimant les
chsct construire la france d'après ce
serait pour suivre la proposition des
parlementaires communistes que vous avez
re rejeté de refuser les aides et prêts
aux sociétés qui ont des actifs dans les
paradis fiscaux
ce serait aussi de rétablir l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune un symbole
fort de l'effort de tous pour la
solidarité nationale monsieur le premier
ministre lorsque notre nation est
confrontée à une crise aussi grave on ne
confine pas ainsi le débat parlementaire
et la démocratie face à cette terrible
épreuve que nous étions depuis le début
disponible pour travailler dans la
solidarité nationale à construire une
issue à cette crise mais au lieu de
construire le combat commun vous avez
choisi de faire cavalier seul
plutôt que de rassembler le pays nous le
regrettons profondément
merci merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur le président
gilles legendre pour la république en
marche
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
messieurs les présidents de groupe
mes chers collègues à partir du 11 mai
la france va devoir réussir l'impossible
reprendre vie sans mettre en danger
celle des français la première crise
sanitaire universel de l'ère
contemporaine que les planètes que la
planète ait connu place tous les pays à
la même enseigne et abolit les immenses
différence qui par ailleurs les
distingue
auparavant aucun d'entre eux absolument
aucun n'avait jamais réalisé ce que nous
sommes invités à engager redémarrer
l'activité alors que la menace sanitaire
qui l'avait contraint à l'arrêt demeure
intacte
et tandis que le virus covit 19 qui
endeuillent chaque jour des centaines de
nos familles et de nos proches n'a
délivré qu'une partie de ces sinistres
secret l'ampleur de la tâche justifie le
débat qui nous réunit est que vous avez
choisi d'organiser monsieur le premier
ministre
seul cas de la sorte dans les grands
pays européens
elle lui donne aussi une solennité qui
n'échappe à personne
vous avez décidé d'observer l'observé
avec le parlement les mêmes principes de
vérité et de transparence qu'avec nos
concitoyens depuis le début de la crise
en réalité c'est à eux que nous nous
adressons aujourd'hui partout dans nos
circonscriptions dans les dernières
heures dans d'innombrables messages
les français nous ont prévenus qu'ils
seraient très nombreux en ce moment à
nous regarder et à nous écouter leur
espoir mêlé d'anxiété dans l'issue que
nous serons capable de leur proposer
pour sortir de l'épreuve nous oblige
tous tous ici à 6 dans cet ami cet
hémicycle
et aussi ceux qui ne peuvent être
présents pour des raisons sanitaires et
que je tiens à saluer nos collègues eric
bothorel camille gaillard minier et
cécile rilhac reviendrons en détail sur
trois aspects essentiels de la stratégie
que vous venez de nous exposer et sur
les conditions très concrète de sa mise
en oeuvre
la logistique sanitaire l'économie
l'école je souhaite pour ma part insisté
sur les enjeux politiques que notre
groupe la république en marche
identifie comme cruciaux pour la
réussite du déconfinement le
déconfinement ce n'est pas encore là
près comme les uns pensent les
impatients voudrait le laisser croire
mais c'est la condition pour que cet
apprêt plus à devenir le plus vite
possible et avec lui à la fois la
réparation et la refondation de notre
pays dans lesquels le président de la
république appelait nos concitoyens à se
projeter
lors de sa dernière allocution
présidentielle
le dic le déconfinement est en quelque
sorte le laboratoire de la presse qu'il
réussisse et tout redevient possible la
france recouvrera le droit de
l'espérance qu'il échoue en tout ou
partie et nos chances s'éloignerait
d'effacer les stigmates de ce choc d'une
violence sans précédent
en réalité le déconfinement pose un
double défi un défi pour les français un
défi pour notre démocratie indique un
défi pour les français tout d'abord
c'est celui de la responsabilité
rien n'est solitaire tout et solidaire
écrivait victor hugo c'est le paradoxe
apparent du confinement est peut-être le
seul bénéfice de cette crise
aujourd'hui plus que jamais alors que
des dizaines de millions de français
sont confinés nous mesurerons la valeur
inestimable du
humain et notre besoin de faire société
depuis deux mois les solidarités grandes
ou petites spectaculaire ou discrète
organisées ou spontanées réveil d'un
capital de générosité une capacité de
résilience un désir de sens dans notre
pays
ceux ci ont toujours existé mais la
course effrénée de l'existence et la
croyance à un progrès éternelle nous
privait trop souvent de les exprimer
avec toutes leurs forces la course
brutalement stoppée et le progrès
gravement mise en doute
nous voici contraint de revisiter
l'essentiel les conditions de notre
survie et les valeurs qui nous unissent
les français ont réussi le confinement
ils sont résolus à réussir le
déconfinement et ils en acceptent les
risques pour vivre que ceux ci soient
contrôlés en sacrifiant partiellement
leur liberté ils ont permis de ralentir
drastiquement la vitesse de circulation
du virus est d'éviter mais de si peu la
saturation de nos hôpitaux au prix il
est vrai du dévouement et du
professionnalisme
admirable de nos personnels soignants
auxquels nous rendons ici un hommage
unanime
le confinement était une discipline
exigeante mais finalement assez simple
sauf exception est essentielle pour
soigner les français ou pour assurer
leur vie quotidienne
nous étions tous invités à rester chez
nous le déconfinement sera autre sera
autrement complexe
son succès repose sur la responsabilité
individuelle
en l'absence de remède ou de vaccin
chacun d'entre nous devient le seul
agent antiviral efficace contre une
seconde vague de l'économe de l'épidémie
qui serait probablement plus d encore
plus dévastatrice les forces de l'ordre
assuraient le respect des règles du
confinement
nous devenons nous mêmes les garants de
nos propres comportements prophylactique
dans tous les actes de notre vie
familiale professionnelle dans nos
déplacements à la maison à lusine au
bureau dans les magasins à l'école
terrible responsabilité
si l'on y songe qui explique les
inquiétudes légitimes de nos concitoyens
et qui appelle de notre part une manière
profondément différente de gouverner
c'est le second défi un défi pour la
démocratie celui de la concorde et du
dépassement nous n'accompliront le
déconfinement que rassemblé et uni et en
sachant recréer l'indispensable
confiance dans l'action publique
ce qui est vrai dans les semaines et les
mois immédiate le sera encore plus pour
engager toutes les forces de notre pays
dans sa reconstruction
ne nous trompons pas les réponses les
réponses du dih confinement sont encore
celle de l'urgence mais l'horizon que
nous devons de se dessiner dès
aujourd'hui est celui du temps long pour
redémarrer l'économie
pour restaurer de nouvelles des
solidarités pour accélérer la transition
écologique
c'est le défi de votre gouvernement
monsieur le premier ministre
et de notre majorité mes essais mais
c'est aussi celui de l'ensemble des
responsables politiques de notre pays
dans les circonstances douloureuses que
nous traversons les français à qui nous
demandons des efforts et des sacrifices
tu ne comprendrait pas que leurs élus
n'entame pas la révolue la réinvention
de leurs propres rites et pratiques
qu'ils ne renoncent pas aux polémiques
stériles qu'il ne trouve ça qu'il ne se
rassemblent pas sur l'essentiel qu'il ne
fasse pas toujours prévaloir le
compromis sur l'affrontement et cela
vaut pour nous tous
la concertation que vous avez instauré
depuis le début de la crise avec les
forces politiques avec les élus locaux
avec les partenaires sociaux avec le
monde associatif doit devenir la pierre
angulaire de ce nouveau pacte
républicain que les français dans leur
très grande majorité appellent de leurs
voeux la méthode retenue pour cette
stratégie de déconfinement s'inscrit
dans cette logique et nous la saluons
sans réserve ce débat au parlement que
vous avez vous voulu et que le président
ne troll de notre assemblée a soutenu
avec la force qu'on lui connaît n'est
pas une fin c'est un début vous l'avez
dit
l'adaptation de la stratégie nationale
aux réalités locales de tous ordres
sanitaires économiques scolaires et
cetera est une condition sinequanone de
son succès confié cette mission au maire
assurément les mieux à même d'en
comprendre les spécificités est le bon
choix
sous réserve que ces acteurs de la
république du quotidien selon
l'expression du chef de l'état et les
préfets sache entraîner tous les acteurs
de ces baisses de ces bassins de vie
services déconcentrés de l'état et
décentralisé acteurs du tissu économique
et du monde associatif notamment ceux
qui agissent en protection des
populations les plus fragiles simples
citoyens au premier rang desquels les
parents d'élèves jusque et y compris
vous n'en serez pas surpris les députés
qui souhaitent prendre toute leur part
au plan de déconfinement
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
vous lu que votre déclaration soit
suivie d'un vote prérogatives que vous
réserve la constitution comme stanislas
guérini le délégué général de la
république en marche l'expliquera tout à
l'heure notre groupe approuvera cette
déclaration avec la gravité et la
détermination qu'imposent les défis que
vous nous proposez de relever avec vous
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président la parole la parole est un
monsieur damien abad président du groupe
l'est républicain la parole du président
[Musique]
le président monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
cette épidémie de couronnes à virus est
branlante pays comme jamais une halle a
sans doute été en temps de paix au cours
de notre histoire récente
ce terrible virus a fait plus de 22
mille morts en france et en cet instant
je pense avant tout à leurs familles et
à leurs proches
avant toute chose au nom de l'ensemble
de mes collègues députés les
républicains et de la représentation
nationale je veux rendre hommage au
travail au courage et au dévouement
admirable de l'ensemble de nos
personnels soignants qui joue un rôle
absolument déterminant pour endiguer
l'épidémie et sauver un très grand
nombre de vies
cette épidémie nous a plongés dans une
crise sanitaire inédites ainsi que dans
une crise économique d'une ampleur
inouïe qui nous impacte collectivement
et qui met chacune et chacun d'entre
nous devant ses responsabilités avec les
républicains nous souhaitons plus que
tout que notre pays soit au rendez vous
de l'histoire est capable de sortir par
le haut du marasme en évitant de sombrer
durablement dans la récession la crainte
et la torpeur les français l'attendent
la situation l'exigent face à une telle
crise sanitaire
nous avons fait le choix d'une
opposition responsable
exigeante et utile à notre pays nous ne
sommes pas là pour participer à un
concours de décibels avec les autres
oppositions mais pour marquer notre
différence notre différence avec eux
mais aussi notre différence avec vous et
votre gouvernement sur la forme comme
sur le fond sur la forme tout d'abord
vous vous remarquerez monsieur le
premier ministre que vous avez eu un
avantage sur nous là vous avez eu 72
heures pour prendre connaissance notre
propre plan de déconfinement vous nous
laissez à peine trois heures pour
examiner le vôtre alors j'avoue ne pas
bien comprendre cet excès de rigidité et
ce d'autant moins qu'il n'ait
apparemment pas partagée par le
président de la république ni par une
partie de votre propre majorité
pourquoi ne pas avoir laissé un délai
d'examen de 24 heures de votre plan au
parlement
pourquoi une telle décision unilatérale
quant à l'argument de l'urgence que vous
invoquez et vous le savez il est
fallacieux voter le texte
aujourd'hui ou demain ne retarde à rien
la mise en oeuvre opérationnelle de
votre plan puisqu'il sera présenté la
semaine prochaine au sénat et qui
n'entrera en vigueur qu'à partir du 11
mai nous déplorons cette crispation
coupable il nous comprenons pas cette
antenne tant qu'il y aura un coût
politique majeur celui de braquer les
oppositions à un moment nous avons
besoin de rassemblement et de sérénité
il est d'ailleurs quelque peu curieux
que le président de la république
appelle à l'unité nationale et que dans
le même temps le premier ministre a soit
sur le parlement et la démocratie quant
à la question du traçage du numérique
nous saluons votre changement en faveur
dans votre spécifiques
compte tenu des nombreuses
interrogations qu'elle suscite au regard
des libertés publiques et individuelles
ainsi que des réels doutes quant à sa
faisabilité pratique pour ce qui est de
votre déclaration
nous avons écouté attentivement notre
inquiétude c'est celle d'un
déconfinement low cost avec une mise en
oeuvre opérationnelle particulièrement
difficile nous constatons d'abord le
risque de déconfinement à protection
variable revenir un instant sur les
masques et les tests il ya quelques
avancées notamment le port obligatoire
du masque dans les transports en commun
mais il reste encore beaucoup de
recommandations et finalement peu
d'obligations dans la sphère publique à
l'exception des transports en commun en
ce qui concerne les tests j'ai entendu
l'objectif
la question c'est comment part bientôt à
cet objectif
comment parvient ton quand on sait les
nombreuses difficultés que nous avons en
france pour déployer cette stratégie de
dépistage massive et puis le risque de
déconfinement parcellaire et reporté je
pense aux cafés hôtels restaurants à ce
que vous venez de déclarer sur les
écoles ou également sur l'application
numérique
nous avons compris aujourd'hui que le
déconfinement ce n'était pas forcément
le 11 mai mais c'était plutôt le 11 mai
avec beaucoup de contraintes et que
c'était même parfois le 2 juin
alors en ce qui concerne ce contenu du
plan de déconfinement nous avons
identifié quatre failles qui nous
paraissent importantes d'abord la
question des protections ensuite la
question des écoles ensuite la question
de la sécurité et la question économique
en ce qui concerne les protections les
masques et
des tests doivent être au coeur de la
stratégie de déconfinement le manque
criant de masques de tests de lits de
réanimation resteront comme des taches
indélébiles et des triste symbole une
gestion souvent chaotique de cette
épidémie
cette pénurie d'équipement aura conduit
malheureusement à des injonctions
contradictoires notamment sur la
question de l'efficacité du port du
masque les députés les républicains
exigent de rendre le port du masque
obligatoire a minima dans les transports
publics mais aussi dans les grandes
surfaces et de l'envisager dans l'espace
public
pour ce qui est des tests nous plaidons
depuis le début pour une stratégie de
dépistage massive systématique
l'allemagne c'est cinq fois plus de
tests que nous et cinq fois moins de
morts si le gouvernement n'est pas en
mesure de fournir à la france
suffisamment de masques et de tests
alors notre pays ira tout droit vers une
seconde vague de les queues de pie
d'ennemis dont les conséquences seraient
bien entendu catastrophiques sur les
écoles
madame annie genevard développera
simplement vous dire qu'après le libre
choix laissé aux familles c'est
désormais le report le report de la
reprise des cours pour les lycéens et
les collégiens alors même que c'est eux
qui peuvent respecter mieux les gestes
barrières que les enfants des écoles
élémentaires ou des écoles maternelles
nous proposons une stratégie de reprise
à l'allemande qui repose sur des tests
massif envers les enseignants et qui
permet de prendre la température de
chaque élève chaque jour avant qu'il ne
rende dans l'établissement je n'ai pas
entendu quelque chose sur les cantines
scolaires
nous avons beaucoup d'interrogations
beaucoup de français ne comprennent pas
comment les restaurants restent pourrait
rester fermé et les cantines scolaires
elles n'ont la deuxième faille c'est
l'absence du volet sécurité je vous ai
écouté attentivement sur le premier
ministre et la sécurité est hélas la
grande absente de ce plan de
déconfinement chez les républicains nous
souhaitons des conditions de sécurité
renforcées contrôler strictement nos
frontières nationales mais aussi
remettre en route nos tribunaux civils
et pénaux et refuser que vingt mille
prisonniers ne soient relâchés plus
rapidement pour des considérations
uniquement pratique
enfin
la dernière faille c'est la question du
redémarrage économique
force est de constater que sur cette
partie là ça manque de souffle et de
conviction nous proposons d'accélérer la
reprise économique
dans les départements les moins touchés
en réouvrant dès le 11 mai les commerces
et cafés hôtels et restaurants notamment
attendre fin mai ou début juin pour ces
départements nous semble tardif
même chose d'ailleurs pour les
bibliothèques comme pour les
médiathèques
pour les autres départements nous
souhaitons d ouverture progressive entre
le 11 mai et le 15 juin
bien sûr cette reprise devra se faire
dans des conditions très acte encadré en
respectant des règles de sécurité
sanitaires strictes telles que l'accueil
du public en nombre restreint où le
respect de la distanciation sociale nous
savons aussi que ces mesures auront un
coût pour les entreprises et nous devons
continuer à les accompagner au quotidien
avec en faisant en sorte que la fin du
chômage partiel soit progressive que le
prêt garanti par l'état soit prolongé au
moins d'un an et que les petites
entreprises continue d'être soutenue par
les aides du fonds de solidarité et nous
souhaitons d'ailleurs l'annulation pure
et simple de l'ensemble des charges
sociales et fiscales j'insiste bien
social et fiscal pour les cafés hôtels
et restaurants mais aussi pour les
commerces pendant la période du
confinement et pendant les deux premiers
mois du déconfinement depuis le début de
cette crise la droite fait preuve de
constance de cohérence et d'esprit de
responsabilité
nous avons voté toutes les mesures
d'urgence nous avons été à l'origine de
nombreuses propositions que ce soit sur
la question du chiffre d'affaires pour
accéder aux fonds de solidarité ou
encore la demande d'autoriser les
pharmacies à vendre des masques en
officier notre marque de fabrique c'est
d'être une force de proposition
parce que nous voulons la réussite de la
france nous avons mis sur la table dès
ce week-end un plan avec 50 propositions
précises et crédibles qui sont le fruit
d'un travail collectif réalisé par
l'ensemble des 104 députés les
républicains ce plan s'articule autour
de deux priorités mieux protéger les
français et accélérer la reprise
économique notre stratégie de
déconfinement se résume en trois mots
masques tests et travail nous voulons
déconfinement clair un déconfinement
sous protection et un déconfinement
territorialisée clair parce qu'il nous
faut donner des perspectives aux acteurs
économiques et de la visibilité à
l'ensemble des français sous protection
car le monde d'après ne peut ressembler
au monde d'avant et que nous ne pouvons
pas nous permettre le risque d'une
nouvelle vague
enfin nous devons avoir un plan de
déconfinement territorialisées nous
croyons nullement un déconfinement
jacobins bureaucratique et
technocratique
nous devons faire confiance aux acteurs
de terrain aux élus locaux et à tous ces
français qui tiennent la france debout
monsieur le premier ministre fait
confiance à tous ces français qui des
caissières de supermarchés aux
transporteurs routiers des agriculteurs
aux ouvriers de l'agroalimentaire des
personnels des ehpad aux aides à
domicile se sont tous retrouvés les
manches pour faire front et servir les
autres faites confiance aux forces vives
de la nation qui des bénévoles
associatifs aux chefs d'entreprises des
organisations professionnelles aux
parlementaires se mobilisent pour
redémarrer l'économie de notre pays fait
confiance aux élus locaux qui dès maires
aux présidents de région n'ont eu cesse
de trouver des solutions de bon sens
pragmatique et ont bien dû souvent
pallier les manques et les défaillances
de l'état
ce plan de déconfinement claire
territorialisée et suis pris sous
protection est un préalable absolu pour
restaurer la confiance des français et
rétablir les conditions d'une sortie de
crise les français ont permis le succès
du confinement
ils attendent désormais que vous soyez
au rendez-vous du déconfinement nous ne
voulons pas mourir guéri voilà pourquoi
nous devons réussir le déconfinement ce
déconfinement c'est un tournant majeur
et c'est une étape décisive
les conséquences sanitaires économiques
et sociales dans déconfinement raté
pourrait s'avérer tout aussi dramatique
que la crise elle-même et pour le
réussir la stratégie doit être clair la
méthode rigoureuse et le cap fixé
hélas
nous sommes jusqu'à maintenant attrapé
par beaucoup d'ordre est de contraindre
les injonctions contradictoires
permanente que nous avons eu ces
dernières semaines brouille totalement
le message et rendent difficilement
applicable la stratégie de déconfinement
un jour on nous dit qu'il est aberrant
de fermer les frontières et le lendemain
on nous dit que la fermeture des
frontières est requise un jour on nous
dit que les écoles réouvriront le 11 mai
et le lendemain que le retour à l'école
se fera finalement sur la base du
volontariat
un jour on nous dit que le déconfinement
sur un régional et le lendemain que
cette option est écartée
un jour on nous dit que les personnes
âgées resteront confinées après la date
du 11 mai et le lendemain et c'est
heureux que finalement cette option est
écartée
un jour on nous dit que les restaurants
réouvriront mi juin et le lendemain que
ce sera finalement pas le cas
monsieur le premier ministre gouverner
c'est décider
l'audace ce n'est pas simplement de
faire preuve de prudence
l'audace c'est aussi de faire preuve de
courage
la politique c'est la décision c'est le
courage et aussi aussi parfois il faut
le reconnaître
la prise de risque alors monsieur le
premier ministre nous voulons le
déconfinement mais nous voulons un
déconfinement claire et sous protection
car sans protection suffisante
c'est l'assurance d'un re confinement
pour faire face à une deuxième vague
sans masque et sentent est suffisant et
malgré ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure nous avons encore des doutes sur
votre capacité à pouvoir mobiliser
suffisamment de masques et de test pour
l'ensemble des français
sans masque et sans test alors nice où
vous serez pris dans l'impasse dans
déconfinement impossible face à de
telles incertitudes et face à ce manque
de courage parfois de clairvoyance et
ses nombreuses volte face vous
comprendrez que les députés les
républicains ne pourront vous apporter
ni confiance ni blanc seing cet après
midi nous sommes quasiment tous unanimes
pour ne pas voter votre plan car comme
plus de six 6 français sur 10 nous
n'avons pas confiance et nous n'avons
plus
sciences alors vous avez certes cet
après-midi poser un cadre théorique
rationnelle mais nous devons désormais
être vigilant tout son ensemble sur la
mise en oeuvre opérationnelle
par conséquent notre groupe nous
voterons majoritairement pour une
abstention vigilante exigeante et
constructive et nous continuerons à être
le porte-voix des interrogations des
français mais également des attentes des
territoires merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur le président
patrick mignola pour le mouvement
démocrate et apparentés merci
si le président sur le premier ministre
madame messieurs les ministres
chers collègues je veux au nom du groupe
du mouvement démocrate et apparentés et
je crois en votre nom à tous commencé ce
propos d'abord en m'inclinant contre
vis-à-vis de ce que le virus à emporter
et envers ceux qui n'ont pas pu les
accompagner ces morts qui n'ont pas pu
leur rendre un dernier hommage au fond
ce cette pandémie aura eu raison de ce
que nous avons parfois de plus intime et
de ce qui faisait que des civilisations
humaines avait connu deux premiers
progrès ça nous invite nécessairement à
placer ce débat le débat qui est le
nôtre aujourd'hui à un niveau de
responsabilité élevée pour agir dans
sept ans inédit que l'histoire récente
nous donne à affronter notre pays va
entrer en rémission et il va entrer en
récession
il va entrer en en rémission parce que
nous avons réussi à freiner la
progression du virus
parce que notre système de santé a tenu
grâce aux soignants grâce aux
travailleurs qui nous ont permis de
continuer à vivre grâce aux forces de
l'ordre
grâce aux confiné parce que les français
ont accepté ce confinement
parce que nous avons accepté d'arrêter
la marche du pays pour protéger les plus
fragiles physiquement et je crois qu'on
cela nous avons donné un sens à ce beau
mot de fraternité
mais attention lorsque
pays est en rémission il n'est pas
encore en guérison est en rémission la
rechute est possible et donc monsieur le
premier ministre oui vous avez bien fait
de poser d'abord des règles de
précaution et d'organisation de la
société qui nous permettent d'éviter
cette rechute
parce que dans la période de rémission
il nous faudra désormais lutter contre
la récession la récession elle touche
d'abord les plus faibles les plus
fragiles de la société économiquement
les chômeurs les allocataires sociaux
les intérimaires et les cdd les
indépendants et cette récession pourrait
amener une régression sociale que nous
devons tout faire pour éviter
et là aussi nous leur devons une strate
hernie tu es désormais nous devons une
fraternité envers les plus fragiles
socialement et au fond telle est notre
responsabilité majeure agir en rendant
compatible ces deux exigences
l'exigence de fraternité envers les plus
fragiles physiquement qu'il nous faut
continuer à protéger et de fraternité
envers les plus fragiles socialement que
nous ne devons pas amené dans des
situations intenables
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons sortir d'un régime de confinement
avec exception pour aller vers un régime
de liberté avec des restrictions
il nous faut l'expliquer ainsi aux
français alors c'est le premier nice
vous avez présenté un plan fondé sur
deux grands piliers un pilier sur le
matériel sanitaire sur les masques sur
les tests sur l' isolement est un pilier
fondée sur des cadres d'action secteur
d'activité par secteurs d'activités
publiques et privées qui sera demain
confié sur le terrain de façon
décentralisée un certain nombre de
collègues qui sont précédés à cette
tribune ont fait part de leurs exigences
que notre travail soit territorialisée
avec le couple maires préfets je me
permettrai même d'aller un peu plus loin
et de considérer que dans le travail qui
va être fait sur le terrain on va
pouvoir réduire la la granulométrie à aa
en dessous du département et que
peut-être par arrondissement et le
couple maires préfets mais le couple
maires préfets
en y ajoutant les parlementaires et en y
ajoutant les partenaires sociaux parce
que c'est bien avec les sous préfets les
parlementaires les élus locaux et les
partenaires sociaux que dans le secteur
public comme dans le secteur privé nous
parviendrons à bâtir un déconfinement
réussies en matière sanitaire
il est important d'avoir remis des
objectifs et de la clarté sur les
masques en redéfinissant la doctrine la
garantie d'en disposer
la méthode pour les utiliser oui bien
sûr nous avons été en difficulté depuis
le début de cette crise est partout sur
le terrain et c'est pas une affaire de
couleur politique ou de département ici
ou là nous avons été en difficulté parce
que à la fois nous avions une doctrine
médical qui n'était pas forcément clair
sur l'utilité ou l'inutilité et nous
avions de toute façon un problème de
disponibilité de ces masques désormais
que nous pouvons grâce à l'action du
gouvernement grâce à l'action des élus
locaux
grâce à la mobilisation industriel
fournir des masques à l'ensemble de la
population
il est bien que nous ayons pu redéfinir
la manière de les utiliser et les
obligations qui seront faites aux
français notamment dans les départements
les plus touchés
et lorsque les règles de distanciation
sociale ne pourront pas être respecté je
sais que ça a fait de grandes polémiques
cette question des masques c'est la
raison pour laquelle il nous faut les
uns et les autres je crois avoir
beaucoup d'humilité sur ce sujet parce
que au fond on a beaucoup glosé et on a
beaucoup entendu dans les médias sur le
la prétendue impréparation du
gouvernement mais objectivement et sans
mettre en cause personne moi depuis une
vingtaine d'années que je suis élu local
et depuis trois ans que je suis
parlementaire je n'ai jamais entendu ni
sur le terrain ni ici lorsque nous
votions le budget de la sécurité sociale
en france
des demandes d'achats massifs
de masques pour reconstituer des stocks
pas plus que je n'ai entendu des
parlementaires ou des élus locaux ou des
responsables publics ou privés réclamer
la rock'n'roll localisation industriels
des masques et donc je crois que les uns
et les autres nous avons à garder un
esprit humble face aux difficultés que
désormais il nous faut régler
vous avez apporté des réponses en
matière de masques vous avez apporté des
réponses en matière de tests je veux
saluer que l'objectif de 700 mille tests
par semaine je salue aussi le challenge
très important que représente des tests
itinérant avec notamment les brigades
sanitaire qui seront sur le terrain et
enfin vous avez évoqué l' isolement
c'est difficile pour les français
nous aurons besoin qu'ils acceptent cet
isolement pour rompre la chaîne de
propagation du virus
parce que ce retrait social provisoire
il faut le redire sera bien une marque
de solidarité sociale majeure qu'ils
consentiront le bloc sanitaire le bloc
territoriales parce que dans la pièce
que nous devons jouer aujourd'hui
évidemment il n'y a pas d'unité de lieux
parce que dans tous les territoires
le virus assez vite de façon différente
il n'y a pas d'unité de temps parce que
la progressivité sera différente ici ou
là mais en revanche il doit y avoir une
unité d'action et l'action est forcément
locales en matière d'école les
différences ne sont même pas régional
même pas départementale parfois même pas
communale elle est à l'intérieur d'une
commune entre les écoles des écoles moi
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être mère pendant 17
ans lorsque nous avons quatre écoles sur
une commune et qu'on envoie 3 ou la
distanciation social est organisables
où les cantines sont suffisamment
spacieuse pour que ça puisse s'organiser
et ben on peut le décider avec son
préfet ou avec son sous préfet et puis
lorsqu'on a une école à l'intérieur même
d'une commune où ça n'est pas possible
il faut trouver d'autres solutions et
effectivement le volontariat et
l'organisation le travail avec les
parents d'élèves
le travail avec les employeurs un
travail social majeur pour savoir quels
sont les élèves qui sont absolument
prioritaire parce que leur situation est
une situation familiale de détresse ce
travail-là se fait au plus près du
terrain et il y aura des départements
vers il y aura des départements rouge et
donc on a entendu ici ou là des maires
la plupart les maires ont envie de
travailler sur le terrain de rendre
service à leur population évidemment on
a entendu ici ou là des maires dire qu'
il ne voudrait absolument pas réouvrir
les écoles et peut-être que dans des
départements rouge
ça pourrait se justifier mais attention
attention responsabilité que nous
prenons que ce soit en tant que
parlementaire bull en tant que maire
attention à des familles qui doivent
reprendre le travail
quand les deux parents travaillent et
que des écoles restent fermées
attention aux familles monoparentales
d'une mère de famille qui serait une
travailleuse indépendante et qui a
besoin de retravailler et donc je le dis
sous le regard du ministre de
l'éducation nationale dans le travail de
terrain qui sera fait par les maires les
préfets et les sous-préfets
il faudra que même dans les zones rouges
où les mères ne peuvent pas ne veulent
pas révéler que des écoles des solutions
soient trouvées en fonction des
situations sociales particulières des
familles telle est l'illustration de ce
que doit être le travail territorialisée
est décentralisée dont ceux des
confinement en matière de travail
il faut en effet que l'activité puisse
reprendre parce que la récession je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure
fera des premières victimes parmi les
français qui sont les plus fragiles
socialement ce travail là aussi doit
être réalisé sur le terrain avec les
partenaires sociaux dans les branches
d'activité avec des guides permettant la
prévention permettant les bonnes
pratiques de telle sorte que demain les
français puissent eux retravaillé et que
notre système économique reprenne vie
parce que si d'aventuré nous devions
affronter une deuxième vague financer
notre système sanitaire ne serait ce que
pour cela nécessitera évidemment que
nous ayons des moyens financiers qui
seront impérativement nécessaire en
matière de commerce vous avez donné
aussi les orientations du gouvernement
de son premier ministre et je veux
saluer le soutien massif que vous avez
décidé avec le président de la
république aux hôtels restaurants
puisque c'est la partie de notre
activité commerciale qui sera le plus
difficilement touché en matière de
transport enfin le travail de terrain
devra s'effectuer et je veux avoir deux
observations particulières
d'abord pour le transport aérien et en
particulier les liaisons aériennes avec
nos outre-mer qui est une réflexion qui
nous faut conduire etc est une forte
attente pour les territoires de ces
morceaux de france là et une deuxième
pensée sur la question de l'île de
france où là les règles que nous devrons
mettre en oeuvre
madame le la ministre de la transition
écologique et des transports les raies
que nous devrons mettre en place devront
être travailler au plus près du terrain
car le port du masque la distanciation
sociale pourrait nous conduire
néanmoins à être en difficulté pour
organiser les plans transport tel qu'il
devrait l'être pour permettre aux
françaises et aux français aux
franciliennes aux franciliens de
reprendre le travail dans de bonnes
conditions
travailler avec les employeurs sur des
horaires différencié pour que le matin
et le soir on puisse élargir les plans
de pics de fréquentation des transports
qu'on puisse travailler au plus près
avec l'ensemble des collectivités
locales pour élargir les plans
transports les réduire à d'autres
moments dans la journée regardez comment
on peut travailler avec d'immenses
système de covoiturage qui sont aussi
une forme de solidarité qu'il nous
faudra organiser et je pense en
particulier aux départements franciliens
or paris tous ces éléments illustrent
que seule la territorialisation et
l'action de terrain seront adaptés pour
réussir le déconfinement et au fond je
crois que cette différenciation
territoriale entre les départements
rouge et les départements vers
permettront à chacun en effet de savoir
où il en est et quelle sera la tension
qu'il devra porter selon là où il habite
pour que lorsqu'on est un département
vert en pis le rester et quand on est
dans un département rouge on puisse en
sortir
pour terminer je voudrais dire deux mots
de de demain parce que la france est en
est en rémission nous devrons aller vers
sa guérison
la france est en récession et nous
devrons éviter toutes les régressions
mais il nous faut aussi penser une
reconstruction et nous devons voir dans
cette sortie progressive de crise une
formidable opportunité bien sûr pour
rebâtir nos souverainetés nous
souveraineté industriels et sanitaires
pour rebâtir des solidarités tels que
les nouvelles solidarités qui viennent
d'être organisées sur le terrain par
tant de françaises et de français puisse
se poursuivre et prenant en compte
évidemment l'impératif écologique dans
la reconstruction du pays qui sera
nécessaire ça nécessitera de
réinterroger beaucoup de nos convictions
nul ne pourra prétendre qu'il faudra
retrouver un libéralisme à tout crin
car qui n'a pas en tête d'une division
internationale du travail qui a conduit
à faire fabriquer des masques et des
tests uniquement en asie nous a conduit
dans l'impasse
mais pour ceux qui veulent que demain
tout l'économie soient nationalisées je
rappelle que nous venons de traverser ce
moment et depuis quelques semaines
l'économie française est nationalisé
puisque c'est nous qui payons les
salaires des salariés c'est nous qui
payons lucky garantissant le capital des
entreprises et donc assez naturellement
nous venons de faire l'expérience que
cette solution devra être réinterrogé
également en matière écologique je crois
que ça nous permettra aussi de trancher
ce très vieux débat sur la croissance ou
la décroissance
puisque nous sommes en période de
décroissance et on voit bien que ceux
qui ont souffrent le plus sont les
français les plus fragiles une foudre a
donc une croissance verte plutôt qu'une
décroissance sombre cet appel à
l'humilité doit nous conduire à réussir
le déconfinement pour construire
probablement un monde meilleur après et
pour que nous puissions continuer de
changer un peu la vie merci monsieur le
président la parole est à monsieur
olivier faure pour le groupe socialiste
et apparentés
c'est toujours
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues le premier ministre nous avons
écouté attentivement vous avez en charge
l'essentiel les vies de milliers de
femmes et d'hommes qui ne résisteraient
pas à l'infection du virus en quelques
mois ce virus amine et non au quotidien
confiné nos existences bouleverser nos
modes de vie transformer nos rapports
aux autres
le confinement a permis d'enrayer la
progression du cosy de 19 mais pas de le
faire disparaître
si c'est une guerre est une guerre de
position une guerre de tranchées et à
chaque jour le front qui s'élargit aux
nouveaux pays
sans vaccin sans traitement fiable sans
immunisation assuré nous allons devoir
vivre avec le virus et surtout la menace
d'une reprise épidémique
alors même que nous serions sont épuisés
et nous implore de leur accorder du
répit plus encore que des zonages nous
partageons avec vous l'objectif du
déconfinement la vie doit reprendre le
travail doit reprendre pour que le
cortège des faillites n'emporte pas les
nombreuses familles déjà fragilisées par
deux mois d'inactivité
la question n'est donc pas celle de
l'objectif mais celle des moyens que
l'on y met face à catastrophe sanitaire
notre devoir est de rechercher ensemble
les moyens nous en sortir le mieux
possible et le plus vite possible
depuis le premier jour nous avons dit
notre disponibilité pour construire une
réponse partager mais nous n'avons
obtenu en retour comme il enseigne de
réunions faux dialogue est vrai
instrumentalisation de ces rendez vous
je dois vous dire monsieur le premier
ministre que j'ai un moment espéré que
cette attitude changerait il y a quinze
jours
quant à lui entamé une discussion avec
l'ensemble des chefs de partis cet
espoir en réalité a été de courte durée
dès le lendemain sans préparation
préalable d'un plan gouvernemental
la date du 11 mai a été posée par le
seul président à ce moment de notre vie
nationale
l'improvisation est coupable elle crée
une défiance à un moment où le pays a au
contraire besoin de repères clairs et
c'est donc tout l'inversé qui s'est
produit en quinze jours nous avons
assisté à un festival de contradictions
d' incohérences approximations sur le
confinement des anciens sur la créature
des écoles sur la régionalisation des
mesures vous avez à l'instant même dû
revoir toutes les annonces faites par le
ministre de l'éducation sur les masques
inutile un jour utile lendemain
obligatoire facultatif en papier en
tissu commandé par arriver et de retard
en déni de dénis en mensonge la doctrine
avaié si souvent que plus personne ne
vous écoute sur ce sujet disons les
choses simplement
personne personne monsieur le premier
ministre ne doit ne devraient être tenus
par le pari du président de la
république
j'ai cru comprendre l'intervention que
vous étiez pas si loin de ce point de
vue le bon moment pour des confiné c'est
le moment où l'on est prêt et à
l'évidence ce que nous rapportent les
maires des enseignants les salariés
c'est que tout est encore loin d'être
prêt ce sont vos propres services qui
disent qu'il n'y a pas assez de masques
pour tous les français et qui imaginent
12 millions de voyages quotidiens dans
le métro sans masque qui imaginent que
le territoire se partage entre ceux qui
ont reçu un masque et ceux qui n'en
trouvent pas on parle de les vendre
alors combien se limiteront à l'achat
d'un seul qu'ils ne renouvelleront pas
faute de moyens
la solution vous la connaissez des
masques gratuits des tests du gel des
blouses des respirateurs tout le reste
n'est que dangereuse diversion tous les
prérequis sanitaires sont connus votre
propre comité scientifique
on a détaillé les principes encore
faudrait-il qu'une existence ne soit pas
purement décorative et lorsque ces avis
ne sont pas suivis nous aimerions
comprendre ce qui motive le gouvernement
en quoi les conditions du retour à
l'école serait établie alors que les
écoliers italien ne retrouveront leur
banc qu'en septembre
comme nos étudiants pourquoi faire
rentrer les plus petits tout de suite
quand on reste prudent pour les
collégiens et les lycéens
si ce n'est que les uns se garde de tout
seul et pas les autres
de nouvelles interrogations naissent
également depuis l'apparition en grande
bretagne en espagne en italie la
syndrome proche de la sociétaire du
corona virus qui frappe les enfants et
nécessite leur hospitalisation en soins
intensifs at elle un lien avec la crise
qui nous occupe
voilà ce que les français attendent de
leurs gouvernants comme de chacun de
leurs élus qu'ils établissent une
évaluation la situation et qui s'assure
que les meilleures garanties lensois
proposé on ne joue pas avec la santé des
français à pile ou face pile on gagne
face l'épidémie repart un déconfinement
raté parce que mal préparés ruinerait
les efforts consentis pendant deux mois
et préparerait une seconde vague dont on
peut redouter la violence ce que veulent
les français ce n'est pas l'accélération
à tout prix du des consignes mans pour
permettre une reprise du travail sans
sécurité agricoles transformés en
garderie sans garantie le courage
monsieur premier ministre ce n'est pas
la marche forcée le courage c'est de
faire les bons choix au bon moment le
déconfinement doit être un moment de
résilience pour tout c'est pour tous pas
le retour au travail pour les uns et le
cauchemar pour les autres
les autres ceux qui ne retrouvent pas
leur travail jeu qui se retrouvent sans
rien au chômage sans revenus il faut
accompagner le déconfinement d'un geste
fort de solidarité
c'est ça la république le président
s'est engagé à ce que
personne ne soit abandonné quoi qu'il en
coûte
at il dit et bien l'heure est venue de
tenir ce bel engagement
les que s'amplifie aux portes des
organisations caritatives
nous allons faire face à une crise
sociale d'une violence inouïe
le chômage croît déjà brutalement les
situations de détresse se multiplient là
aussi il est nécessaire d'anticiper
demain il sera trop tard il faut
empêcher les expulsions locatives dans
le parc social aider davantage les
familles précarisées les étudiants isolé
en finir avec cette fabrique industriels
à pauvreté qu'est votre réforme de
l'assurance chômage
il faut un plan d aide alimentaire
massif et une mobilisation générale
son soutien individualisé aux jeunes
décrocheurs une est retrouvé les stages
et apprentissage on ne peut pas laisser
un cinquième de notre jeunesse
les mesures de chômage partiel très bien
ce que nos voisins allemands avaient
fait dès 2008 nous le faisons enfin et
nous vous rejoignons de pleinement sur
ce sujet mais ne nous satisfaisons pas
trop vite
ce sont aussi des pertes de pouvoir
d'achat parfois terribles quand la part
variable
les primes les heures supplémentaires ne
me rentre plus à la maison jusqu'à 2
smic et demi il serait juste de
compenser les salaires à 100%
vous nous répondre et que c'est sans
doute beaucoup d'argent sans doute mais
moins que celui que nous perdons
accorder des aides publiques à des
entreprises qui continuent à verser des
dividendes ou qui placent leur argent
dans des paradis fiscaux
c'était une de vos promesses mais vous
ne l'avez pas tenus lors du vote de la
loi de finances rectificative tenez là
arrêtez d'être fort avec les faibles et
faible avec les forts les annonces
ça ne peut pas être réservé à ceux qui
ne respectent pas le confinement
il n'y a pas d'argent magique disait le
président c'est vrai mais il y a des
magiciens qui
save le rendre transparent à nos regards
alors si vous voulez faire du tracking
traquer l'argent sale celui qui s'évade
quand tous les français sont appelés au
civisme si vous voulez que notre présent
anticipe un après différents doc plus
solidaire rétablissez dès à présent lisf
abroger la flat tax suspendait tous les
cadeaux fiscaux indécent aux plus riches
quand vous n'accordez qu'une prime à une
partie de ceux qui tiennent aujourd'hui
ce pays debout trolls et des engagements
forts montrer au pays que comme nous
vous avez appris cette crise
je ne savais pas mon propos sans vous
parlez aussi de culture mais aussi de
nos bars de nos restaurants de tout ce
qui rend nos vie plus belle
il faut un vrai plan de réveil de la vie
sociale culturelle sportive associative
pour que le tissu social ne s'effondre
pas et que nos vies demain garde la même
richesse
monsieur le premier ministre j'achève
nous ne voulons pas de principes de mots
nous voulons des actes c'est la raison
pour laquelle monsieur le premier
ministre vous n'aurez pas aujourd'hui
notre vote
nous ne voulons plus de généralités mais
un mode d'emploi détaillé
nous ne voulons pas de ce vote d'un seul
bloc
nous ne voulons pas de chèque en blanc
nous voulons une action concertée
transparente et qui offrent les
meilleures garanties aux français les
maires ne peuvent plus continuer à être
méprisé convoquée pour mettre en oeuvre
les décisions que l'état inspire seul
sans consignes claires sans soutien être
un dialogue véritable dans cette crise
le gouvernement a raté son rendez vous
avec le pays
ces territoires ses forces sociales
comme depuis trois ans le président fait
seul avec cette méthode
il nous fait prendre à tous le risque
d'échouer nos collectivités locales
évidemment comme nous-mêmes aideront
dans toute la mesure du possible à la
réussite de déconfinement mais ne nous
demandez pas vous accorder une confiance
que jusqu'à ce jour
vous ne méritez pas merci
collègues la parole est à monsieur le
président jean christophe lagarde pour
le groupe u10 agir et indépendants pour
cinq minutes
v la parole monsieur le président
le président monsieur le premier
ministre difficile en quelques minutes
de n'être d'apprécier un plan très large
tel que vous l'avez donné je veux
d'abord affirmé que les députés udf
partage l'idée qu'il faut choisir entre
déconfinement effondrement est en
réalité il n'y a pas de choix il faut
des confiné et la question c'est le
comment il ya dans votre intervention
d'abord des choses qui me paraissent
positive et de bonne nouvelle le fait
qu'on ne soit pas sûr que ce soit le 11
et que vous conditionner sa un certain
nombre de critères
je les rappelle le taux de nouveaux cas
l'état de nos services d'urgence
recomposition du matériel des
médicaments mais aussi du potentiel
humain notamment dans les départements
et les territoires les plus éprouvés la
capacité en test qu'on doit pouvoir dont
on doit pouvoir disposer pour pouvoir
améliorer de déconfinement le 11 mai
mais aussi il me semble vous avez oublié
la disponibilité des masses parce que
les matchs ne seront pas disponibles
partout sur le territoire
en même temps les collectivités locales
on en demande commande et tout en même
temps et donc elle ne les recevrons pas
tout en même temps permettant de
garantir les protections nécessaires
d'ailleurs vous avez clarifier leurs
nécessités je vous en remercier en vous
disant quand même que personne ne
semble-t-il n'a jamais contesté le fait
qu'elle soit réservée aux soignants mais
qu'on n'ait pas dit très clairement aux
français puisque nous n'en avons pas
assez
ce sont les soignants qui sont
prioritaires parce que si les soignants
meurt il n'y a plus personne pour nous
soigner
je crois que tous les français auraient
compris ça et ça aurait permis plus de
confiance qu on en constate aujourd'hui
dans la population pour réunir ces
critères pour en juger
il faudra que les élus puissent en juger
eux mêmes
il en va aussi de leurs responsabilités
et plus si je peux me permettre monsieur
le préfet que celle que les préfets qui
font un travail remarquable mais qui ne
rendent pas de compte à la population
deuxième point positif le fait devancer
par étapes de trois semaines on verra ce
que donne le critère des départements
vert au rouge je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
faille attendre trois semaines à chaque
fois mais en tout cas qu'on avance par
étapes et pas comment dirais-je d'une
d'un seul bloc
après j'ai relevé un certain nombre de
contradictions peut-être lié à des
incompréhensions ou des incomplétude
vous parlez de terrorisation mais
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale on nous dit que toutes les
écoles doit rouvrir en même temps y'a
pas territorialisation si c'est toutes
les écoles partout en même temps vous le
dites que les plages vont être fermés
partout mais
franchement il ya des territoires où le
virus n'a quasiment pas circuler non je
ne pense pas qu'on soit plus confiné ou
plus en difficulté ou plus en danger
dans une place que dans une médiathèque
qu'en revanche vous souhaitez laisser
libre d'ouverture même si j'imagine
il y aura des limites nous avait dit que
les crèches serait limitée à 10 je n'ai
pas très bien compris cette partie là et
j'imagine que les jours qui viennent
nous permettront d'y voir plus clair
mais j'ai surtout pas compris pourquoi
vous choisissez de prioriser dans les
crèches ou de demander qu'on priorise
dans les crèches et vous avez raison les
familles monoparentales les gens qui
sont obligés de travailler et que vous
ne faites pas la même chose dans les
maternelles ou entre nous soit dit les
règles de 17 associations sociales sont
strictement impossible à appliquer à ce
sujet je vous ai interrogé lors d'autres
réunions et je leur fais ici
est-ce que des maires qui refuseront
ouverte et d'ouvrir les maternelles se
verront obligés de le faire par les
préfets et qui en portera la
responsabilité pénale
je pense également qu'on a oublié qu'il
fallait testé massivement les adultes
intervenant en milieu scolaire des
enseignants les personnels des
collectivités locales voire des sociétés
qui s'y trouvent
c'est ce qu'on a fait avant le
confinement ou ont fermé les écoles
quand un adulte été contaminés je pense
qu'il vaut mieux le faire en amont pour
éviter qu'une affection menace le
personnel et les uns et des enfants de
nos écoles
et puis il ya des incertitudes qu il
vous appartiendra de préciser par
exemple vous avez dit que dans les
départements vers les parcs et jardins
pourrait rouvrir très franchement dans
les départements qui resteront en rouge
sans jeu de mots quand je pense à la
seine saint denis compte dans les
départements qui resteront en rouge
il ya besoin d'aérer la population qui
est confiné dans des conditions de
logement très difficiles et nous avions
un système qui permettait de réguler
dans les parcs où c'est possible le
nombre d'entrants je vous demande d'y
réfléchir
vous avez évoqué comme incertitude
également les déplacements
interdépartementaux si j'ai bien compris
sur attestation en fonction des motifs
c'est l'attestation qui demeureraient
mais je vous le dis tout de suite le sur
le premier disque
quid des vacances parce qu'il y aura
sans doute encore des départements dans
le rouge au moment des vacances
je n'ai pas compris comment vous
entendiez limiter le nombre de passagers
dans les transports en commun par
exemple dans le métro à paris puisque il
faut étaler bien sûr mais on ne pourra
pas facilement empêcher les gens de
rentrer dans la même rame sachant qu'ils
ont eux aussi une pression est connu
ig et sociales importantes vous avez dit
que les allemands seraient sur le
volontariat je veux attirer votre
attention de shell premier l'isla encore
sur des personnes qui pour s'isoler
devrait se couper de leur travail
il faut compenser leur situation
évidemment sous forme d'arrêt maladie ça
me semble une évidence
vous avez dit que l'application s'était
pas maintenant mais après je ne sais pas
si celle ci serait utile je veux
simplement dire à tous les français
qu'après examen et même si nous avions
des incertitudes au début celles ci ne
nous pensent ne nous paraît pas poser de
problème en termes de libertés publiques
et puis vous avez abordé un état
d'urgence plus plus longtemps
celui ci nous laisse inquiets parce
qu'il ya des adaptations à ferme mais
pas à vivre sous un régime d'exception
en permanence vous nous avez invité jeu
conclut monsieur le président à enrichir
le dispositif au cours des semaines qui
viennent nous le ferons volontiers il
est dommage que vous ne faisiez pas
laissé le temps d'y réfléchir
aujourd'hui d'en échanger et d'en
débattre entre nous 15 jours pour
établir un plan de godet confinement
pour le gouvernement une heure pour nous
décider pour ce qui concerne nos groupes
ce qui expliquera d'ailleurs la
diversité des votes
au fond le succès du nez confinement ne
dépend que d'une chose le retour de la
confiance des français dans la parole
publique et particulièrement de ses
responsables politiques gouvernementaux
sinon ils ne remettront pas leurs écoles
leurs enfants dans les écoles ils ne
remettront pas l'heure ils n'iront pas
travailler
ils n'iront pas dans les transports mon
jugement personnel monsieur le premier
ministre c'est que le jus le traitement
et le suivi de la crise économique par
le gouvernement a été bien fait le suivi
sanitaire laisse aujourd'hui encore
beaucoup d'interrogations dans les têtes
des français c'est sur celui là que vous
devez narguer regagner leur confiance
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur eric bothorel pour le
groupe de la république en marche
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues nos
connaissances sont une goutte notre
ignorance un océan disait isaac newton
soulignant ainsi les limites de l'esprit
humain pour appréhender les phénomènes
naturels et les lois qui les régissent
ses limites
nous nous y aurons également face à un
objet aussi complexe que la gestion
d'une épidémie causée par un virus qui
rappelons le était inconnu de tous il ya
quelques mois et depuis a conduit la
moitié d'humanité à se confiner faute de
mieux
en effet sans vaccin ou traitement
disponible dès lors que la circulation
du virus n'ait pu être circonscrite à
quelques kloster nous l'allons guère
d'autre choix que de prendre cette
décision éprouvante pour ralentir
l'épidémie soulager nos systèmes de
santé et sauver un maximum de vies cette
stratégie de confinement s'est montré
tout aussi efficace que terriblement
coûteuse efficace car le confinement a
permis d'endiguer la première vague
d'épidémie avec succès le taux de
transmission du virus dans la population
ayant été réduits d'au moins 80% mais
cette stratégie est coûteuse car outre
son impact économique
le confinement engendre une grande
souffrance chez bon nombre de nos
concitoyens
il faut donc en sortir mais de façon
progressive car il levait soudaine des
mesures de contrôle fait courir le
risque d'une deuxième vague et d'un
bilan humain désastreux la sortie du
confinement doit donc s'inscrire dans la
continuité de la stratégie de contrôle
de l'épidémie
en ce sens nous devons poursuivre le
même objectif limiter l'apparition de
nouvelles infections est traitée le plus
efficacement possible les cas détectés
afin de limiter le nombre de formes
graves protéger tester isolé c'est en
substance ce que vous avez présenté tout
à l'heure monsieur le premier ministre
ces stratégies doivent nécessairement
être souple et adaptatif car de l'aveu
des experts réunis au sein du conseil
scientifique
nous ne savons pas de quoi demain sera
fait
compte tenu de cette incertitude il nous
faut mobiliser tous les moyens
disponibles tous les moyens disponibles
masque test gestes barrières
distanciation social outils
technologiques
il en va de notre capacité à alléger les
contraintes que les français subissent
et éviter à tout prix la perspective
nord confinement pour ce faire le
conseil scientifique a formulé plusieurs
axes stratégiques dans son abri du 20
avril et je me félicite que le
gouvernement s'inscrivent dans son
sillage nous avons réussi le confinement
et pour réussir le déconfinement
il ya plusieurs paires eric et à remplir
d'une part nous devons fournir à tous
nos concitoyens des équipements de
protection pour réduire la transmission
du virus et d'autre part identifié
systématiquement les cas suspects afin
de les tester et le cas échéant les
isoler c'est en ce sens que l'état les
collectivités les acteurs économiques et
des systèmes de santé publique ont
travaillé sans relâche
si certains pouvaient encore dire au
début du mois d'avril que la france
n'avait pas les moyens de sonder
confinement les choses ont changé depuis
ainsi nous avons reconstituer nos stocks
de protection matérielle et pour les
mettre à disposition de toute la
population le 11 mai en fonction des
besoins pour les masques chirurgicaux et
ffp2 préserver en priorité aux soignants
et aux personnes très exposé cette
reconstitution était progressive car les
chaînes d'approvisionnement en
provenance de chine ont été rompues il a
fallu structurer une filière
industrielle depuis mars
tous les efforts ont été entrepris afin
d'augmenter les capacités de production
national et multiplier les commandes à
l'étranger
nous produisons actuellement 10 millions
de masques par semaine les ouvriers en
interne au betis de 20 millions fin mai
parallèlement le pont aérien mis en
place et avec la chine fonctionne et
nouvelle commande de 100 millions
d'unités est attendu cette semaine pour
la population générale des masques
alternatives de production industrielle
ou artisanale suffisait doivent pas
distribuer en priorité aux en perse aux
personnes en contact régulier avec le
public pour cette catégorie plus de 41
millions d'unités ont déjà été produites
depuis le 30 mars et 242 entreprises
présentes sur le sol français se sont
positionnés sur ce marché ce qui nous
permettra d'atteindre le métier de 38
millions la semaine du 11 mai
réutilisables jusqu'à 20 fois ses
masques conviendront à la plupart des
activités professionnelles classique et
à la vie de tous les jours cela étant il
faut rappeler que le port de ces masques
peut donner un faux sentiment de
sécurité
il n'est réellement efficace que s'il
est couplé à un strict respect des
mesures barrières et de distanciation
sociale en tout état de cause il
conviendra de veiller scrupuleusement à
ce que des équipements soient
disponibles sans risque de rupture
d'approvisionnement et à des tarifs
abordables pour tous sur les masques
grand public
nous voyons déjà apparaître des
pratiques de prix abusifs avec certaines
officines qui les commercialisent à 10
euros alors que les prix attendues sont
de l'ordre de 2 à 5 euros
ces trafics ces pratiques sont
parfaitement inacceptables et bien que
cette piste n'était écartée
peut-être faudrait-il reconsidérer
la question de l'encadrement tarifaire
par ailleurs il me semble que nous
pourrions utilement nous appuyer sur la
mobilisation des réseaux de fab lab et
de mekkera dépendants qui ont joué un
rôle important depuis le début de la
crise et ont permis de réduire les
pénuries de matériel de protection et de
soins cette formidable énergie doit être
soutenu et à tout le moins il faut nous
garder de toutes initiatives
réglementaires qui viendraient freiner
l'innovation locale territoriales celle
de vos fablab de tous vos territoires de
vocaux tour hier de tous vos territoires
parallèlement l équipement la population
en matériel de protection
réussir le déconfinement suppose de
déployer des capacités d'identification
rapide des cas de leurs contacts et
d'isolement de patients de tous les
porteurs sains et contagieux ses
capacités d'identification nécessite de
disposer de test fiable en nombre
suffisant et de déployer des moyens
logistiques et humains très importants
sur l'ensemble du territoire sur le
sujet dès tests d'abord attention à
rester prudents vis-à-vis des tests
sérologiques qui présente encore des
limites importantes et n'ont qu'un
intérêt relatif pour un usage individuel
dans un premier temps ils devraient
plutôt servir aux enquêtes
épidémiologiques visant à déterminer le
niveau d'immunité de la population
ce sont en effet les test dit pcr qui
doit être le principal outil du
diagnostic et du contrôle de l'épidémie
l'enjeu des prochaines semaines et donc
de prévoir leur disponibilité à larges
et celle sur tout le territoire
la semaine dernière plus de 210 m 270
mille tests pcr ont été réalisés
nos capacités et en doublé en 15 jours
et continue d'augmenter pour atteindre
l'objectif des 500 milles à 700 mille
tests par semaine au 11 mai toutefois
tester toute la population n'est ni
réaliste ni souhaitable sur la prendrait
trop de temps et de donnerait une image
transitoire de la situation les tests
pcr devrait être plutôt concerne
concerner toute personne qui présente le
moindre symptôme évocateur afin de
l'isoler
si elle est positive ces contacts
devront être également identifié tester
et isolé si nécessaire une telle
stratégie nécessitera une forte
mobilisation de personnel formé et une
logistique humaine importante
il s'agira en effet de constituer une
force sanitaire une fameuse brigade
sanitaire d'environ 20000 à 30000
personnes qui remplira des missions de
détection et d'orientation des cas
d'évaluation des risques de transmission
et de recommandations de la stratégie
d'isolement à suivre il s'agira
également de prévoir un maillage
important d'infrastructures sur le
territoire net
donald pour rendre les tests accessibles
facilement ses infrastructures et
équipes devront être mises en place et
coordonnée aux niveaux différents
niveaux régionaux territoriaux ou plus
proche de la population
elles pourront être constituées par les
mobilisations de médecins de personnels
paramédicaux de volontaires du personnel
a recruté une formation opérationnelle
et délivrant les prérequis en matière de
confidentialité des données devraient
être dispensés à chacune des composantes
de ces services car dans ce dispositif
sanitaire les outils numériques ont
vocation aucune place à occuper une
place toute particulière
ils ont d'abord un rôle clé à jouer pour
soutenir la logistique et permettent la
bonne intégration des différentes étapes
du processus notamment concernant la
réalisation des tests
le rendu des résultats est l' alerte
rapide des personnes positives la
recherche des contacts ou encore le
transfert des données en temps réel au
système de surveillance épidémiologique
sujet largement maîtrisé par des
collègues ici présents comme tera la raf
en devenir mahjoubi j'oublie beaucoup de
monde par donc pour ceux qui auraient
oublié
en ce sens la situation appelle à la
construction d'un système d'information
répartie simple interopérables et dans
les agents permettant l'exploitation et
la consolidation des données
en complément certains outils numériques
facilitant le contact racing peuvent se
révéler extrêmement précieux pour
renforcer l'efficacité de ce dispositif
permettez moi à ce titre de dire un mot
du projet d'application stop vide qui a
suscité de nombreuses polémiques et
divise sur tous les bancs jusqu'à
certains membres de notre majorité
ce débat est légitime et sur des sujets
ayant trait aux libertés et droits
fondamentaux
il est cinq différentes sensibilités
s'expriment je ne m'écarterai pas de ce
qu'a dit le premier ministre à ce sujet
tout à l'heure pour ce qui est de notre
groupe dans sa majorité je crois pouvoir
dire qu'il est favorable à tout outil
numérique éthique encadré protecteur du
consentement et de la vie privée de
l'utilisateur et efficace sur le plan
sanitaire et c'est bien sûr nous avons à
faire ainsi que le rappelle la cnil au
conseil national du numérique dans leurs
amis respectifs
à condition de prévoir des garanties
suffisantes nous y serons
particulièrement attentifs
pour certains cette application serait
d'emblée assimilables aux technologies
de surveillance et plus invasives comme
la reconnaissance faciale il faudrait la
refuser par principe sans même étudier
les possibilités de lignes rouges où son
utilité potentielle
rien n'est plus irresponsable à mes yeux
finalement nous ne sommes pas très loin
les observateurs mal avisé
et qui par le passé ont jugé inutile de
conserver un stock d'un milliard de
masques pour ensuite lorsque le bronze
besoin s'est fait sentir nous expliquer
qu'il aurait fallu le préserver
personnellement je considère qu'il est
préférable dans le cas d'une crise
sanitaire d'écouter les épidémiologistes
lorsqu'ils avancent qu'un tel outil peut
être utile et qu'il est possible de
concevoir dans le respect de nos valeurs
ne céderons rien à l'ultra crépy
d'ariane isme écouter longue
ecoutons-les donc certes sans naïveté et
attendons de voir si cette application
fait ses preuves
quitte à l'abandonner si tu n'aimes pas
le cas au moins nous on a pris toutes
les précautions pour disposer de notre
propre outil souverain chers collègues
je conclurai mon port aux propos en
insistant sur les difficultés et les
incertitudes qui se présentent devant
nous si nous avons fait avancer notre
connaissance du virus ces derniers mois
de nombreuses inconnues demeurent la
certitude que nous avons acquise c'est
que le confinement et les gestes
barrière fonctionne pour ce qui est du
de confinement de nous y préparons nous
avons bon espoir mais sans garantie
définitive l'avenir est incertain et il
faut assumer une part de risque nous ne
pouvons pas nous contenter de réfléchir
à toutes les options possibles pendant
que le virus continue à sévir car le
temps est son meilleur allié
en temps normal nous évaluerions d'abord
et essayions ensuite il nous faut agir
expérimenté évaluer nos actions et les
réviser si nécessaire les défis
logistiques humains et technologiques à
règles pour contrôler l'épidémie en
sortie de confinement sont considérables
les deux prochaines semaines seront
cruciales pour renforcer les moyens dont
nous avons besoin mais les progrès sont
déjà là et les entailles sont prises
sont les bonnes je vous invite donc au
nom du rouble la république en marche à
voter en faveur de l'opération du
gouvernement merci
[Applaudissements]
d'écouter la parole la parole est à
monsieur eric ciotti pour le groupe
l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente j'espère que
monsieur le premier ministre nous a pas
déjà quittées en tout cas madame et
messieurs les les ministres 23 mille
morts 23 mille morts dont neuf mille de
nos aînés dans le huis-clos terrible des
ehpad 28000 hospitalisations dont 4600
encore en réanimation
des dizaines de milliers de familles
sont touchées au coeur ces chiffres
terrifiants font de la france le
quatrième pays le plus frappé au monde
en même temps plus de 11 millions de nos
compatriotes se trouvent à l'activité
partielle comme l'on dit pudiquement le
chômage a quant à lui bondi de 7% en
mars
des records inédits des artisans des
commerçants des professions libérales
des chefs d'entreprise vivent
aujourd'hui dans la terreur du lendemain
des vies ont disparu d'innombrables sont
encore menacées d'autres seront
bouleversées face à cette tragédie n'est
dit
les français ont été exemplaire de
courage et de mobilisation je pense
notamment à nos formidables personnels
de santé auxquels je veux dire notre
infinie reconnaissance dans ce contexte
monsieur le premier ministre vous
solliciter aujourd'hui notre confiance
avant de nous prononcer avant de me
prononcer il est utile de se demander si
vous en êtes digne
le président macron a parlé de guerre
mais pour l'heure c'est une bérézina qui
nous a frappés et les chefs de guerre
n'ont pas brillé
certes n'est pas de gaulle ou clemenceau
qui veut oui nous avons subi un joint 40
sanitaires je dresse avec tristesse ce
constat oui monsieur le premier ministre
je me réjouis de votre retour
vous n'avez pas su anticiper
suffisamment cette crise
à chaque étape de la pandémie mais aussi
bien avant vous avez manqué de
clairvoyance et de prévoyance
que d'erreurs des erreurs fatales qui
ont coûté si cher à notre pays en 2018
et 2019
vous n'avez pas suivi les rapports qui
exigeaient le renouvellement des stocks
stratégiques de masques alors tombé au
plus bas depuis le départ de nicolas
sarkozy qui en avait laissé 1 milliard
400 millions
il était à peine 100 millions en janvier
2020 le 24 janvier
agnès buzyn déclaré que le risque
d'importation du coronavirus depuis la
chine était quasi nulle
ouvrant une longue période de près d'un
mois d'inertie avant que les premiers
cas n'apparaissent en italie le 23
février
ici même en réponse à ma question vous
refusiez toute forme de fermeture voire
même de contrôle de nos frontières
aveuglés par l'idéologie d'un monde où
la frontière est et assimilés par le
président matheron au nationalisme
devenu plus dangereux que le virus
pourtant les frontières au mieux et plus
efficacement protégé les pays qui les
ont fermé plus rapidement que nous comme
l'allemagne l'autriche le portugal le 6
avril
vous soulignez vous-même que porter un
masque dans la rue ne sert à rien le 13
avril le président macro indiqué testé
que tester toute la population n'aurait
aucun sens
le 6 mars il invitait à sortir au
théâtre le 13 mars il récuser lui aussi
le port du masque pendant des mois vous
avez délivré des affirmations toujours
péremptoire fréquemment contradictoires
et souvent erronées tout cela pour
dissimuler la vérité l'absence cruelle
de masques de tests de respirateurs au
final l'allemagne qui n'a pas connu ces
pénuries a su anticiper s'équiper tester
compte cinq fois moins de morts que la
france
cette vérité nous la devons aujourd'hui
aux français crise sanitaire majeure
crise économique inédite
rice sociale demain nous y sommes
prenons garde également à l'apparition
d'une violente crise sécuritaire
cette crise elle est déjà là en fait
violence urbaine violation du
confinement agression de policiers de
gendarmes de pompiers attentat islamiste
cette crise à l'action de tuer encore un
peu plus attractifs dans cette france
qui respectent les lois et celle qui ça
n'a franchi des rodéos des attroupements
toléré dans des quartiers selon des
instructions données par votre
gouvernement l'intransigeance ailleurs
faible avec les forts et fort avec les
faibles
voilà ce qu'ont ressenti beaucoup de
français nous vous mettons en garde
contre ces menaces
or vous n'avez pas dit un mot monsieur
le premier ministre pas un seul mot nous
vous demandons de réouvrir les tribunaux
de réouvrir les centres de rétention
administrative pour accueillir les
clandestins les plus dangereux
nous vous demandons de stopper les
libérations de détenus certains
radicaliser à ce rythme il y en aura 20
mille de moins offrait enfin aux
policiers aux gendarmes
véritable oubliés de la république et
nous le devons là aussi considération et
respect le les moyens qu'ils méritent et
team en prime et paiement des heures
supplémentaires
d'autres crises viendront sans doute
peut-être plus grave encore la meilleure
arme face à ces crises c'est un état
fort et respecté réarmer enfin l'état
dans cette crise c'est avec des vies
humaines que notre peuple a soldé ses
erreurs et ses retards
comme l'écrivait déjà en 1940 le général
de gaulle or face à cette étrange
défaite nous ne sommes toujours pas prêt
c'est pour cela monsieur le premier
ministre que je n'approuverait pas votre
plan monsieur le député
la parole est à monsieur hervé saulignac
du groupe